for Britain's space industry brexit is
both a challenge and an opportunity will
be prevented from accessing the highly
accurate military-grade signal of the
Galileo sat-nav system but the
government is so concerned about the
threat to national security that is
willing to spend up to 5 billion pounds
building an alternative Clyde space is
one of those hoping to pick up the
business pitching a radical plan of
using a constellation of thousands of
tiny satellites they could cover a whole
region with pinpoint accuracy for just a
tenth of the cost you could have a
system that's far more precise and
accurate than existing systems even
Galileo that mean you have only a
limited amount of time you can use that
as it passes overhead but during that
time you could do a lot of different
things that could be to do with
construction or maybe say state
management or military or other
applications but you you would know when
you're going to have that capability and
you would use it at that point Clyde
told Sky News its proposal has been
rejected as too risky by the government
which is instead looking for more
traditional alternatives to Galileo but
that's proving expensive there are big
questions though whether the 90 million
pounds the government is spending on its
Galileo contingency plans really offers
good value currently the satellites that
are built here have to be launched from
as far away as New Zealand and yet if
the same amount of money had been spent
accelerating development of a spaceport
just 200 miles up the road it would have
been a boon for the UK space industry
there's another obstacle to get round
space is already crowded with satellite
navigation systems launched by the US
Russia China Japan and India as well as
the EU each provides a precise military
signal and a less accurate one for
public use the entire spectrum of
frequencies has already been divided up
there's nothing left for Britain if
Britain was to build a new system it
would have to get all those countries to
agree on which part of the spectrum it
would have to take spectrum from other
people who have now been assigned it so
that is a big geopolitical headache for
Britain to try and resolve if it goes
ahead with its own
navigation system I put that to the
science minister he insisted allies
would give up capacity for Britain's
benefit we speak to a number of our
allies and there is there is opportunity
here for us and there's we can't sort of
discuss everything because this is part
of our security needs and there are a
lot of our conversations that go on but
there is a way in which we can deliver
something that is consistent with our
military needs but with other allies
willing to work with us whatever happens
Britain will still have access to the
American GPS system even for weapons so
is it worth the cost and diplomatic
effort of us trying to find our own way
Thomas More Sky News